Happiness, as an emotion, is one on a spectrum
of many.
It is, of course, our favorite emotion though,
and we dedicate our entire lives trying to
isolate it.
But even if we could control the conditions
of life to solely produce happiness, we should
not want to.
Without negative emotions, we would never
know what feels positive.
We do not want the emotion of happiness to
be permanent, because without binary contrast,
there is no distinction between emotions and
therefore, there becomes none.
What we need is a different kind of happiness.
A happiness that comes from the appreciation
of the idea that we are able to feel and experience
the entire spectrum of life and emotion.
We must not confuse attempting to achieve
a sense of wonder and stimulation in life
with attempting to achieve the emotion of
happiness.
It is good to feel the emotion of happiness
and we should try our best to do so as much
as possible, but when we chase the idea that
this happiness can be a ceaseless and constant
state of being, we remain in a never-ending
pursuit, attempting to blockade the ebb-and-flow
of life.
But of course, this is impossible.
The flow of life is far too strong and powerful
to dam.
There are too many moving parts for everything
to always work in favor of just one person…
including you.
You must, instead, be appreciative that you
are not always happy and that life thinks
your worthy of experiencing the incredible
array of emotions.
Things won’t always be good and things won’t
always be bad, but at least they will always
be.
Deep down, we fear a life of complete certainty
and happiness.
If our lives were free from all problems,
our only remaining problem would be not having
any.
Our sense of purpose would dissolve.
We would stand still in a world that is in
constant motion.
In order to be a part of the life around us,
we must move with it and accept the flow of
ups and downs.
You must be like a garden.
Out of which the entire spectrum of emotions
can grow.
As the seasons and conditions of life change,
certain plants will bloom while others will
die.
But as the cycle rotates, your garden will
remain rich, sustainable, and full of life.
Ironically, by maintaining an appreciation
for the whole spectrum of emotions, happiness
will appear more often in your life and you
will get what you really wanted in the first
place.